singing vouching about you tomorrow  jingle bell swing and jingle bells ring  snow when a blowing up bushels of fun  now the jingle hop has begun jingle bell  jingle bell Jingle Bell Rock jingle  bells chime in jingle bell time dancing  and prancing in jingle bell square in  the frosty air water right time is the  right time to rock the night away jingle  bell time is a swell done you go riding  in a one-horse sleigh giddy-up jingle  speak up you bleep jingle around I'm  it's an anime go in the jingle lb that's  the jingle hi on this glorious broad day  from the staff of the gore District  Council we wish you all a very merry  christmas and a happy and safe new year  take here